[Music]
cloud data loss prevention is a fully
managed service designed to help you
discover
classify and protect your most sensitive
data you can inspect
mask and de-identify sensitive data such
as personally identifiable information
or pii
secrets and credentials cloud dlp
integrates natively with security
command center
when you use cloud dlp to scan your gcp
storage repositories
it can send results directly to the
security command center dashboard
please note cloud dlp uses its own
pricing structure
separate from security command center
premium a link to pricing information
is available in the description below
before you can send cloud dlp scan
results to security command center
you must set up the following components
identify gcp storage repositories
set cloud iam roles enable security
command center
enable cloud dlp enable cloud dlp
as a security source for security
command center
and define a dlp inspect job
step 1 identify gcp storage repositories
you can choose whether you want to scan
your own gcp storage repository or an
example one
if you want to scan your own existing
cloud storage bucket
bigquery table or cloud datastore kind
first open the project that the
repository is in
in the next steps you'll enable cloud
dlp for this project
and its organization step 2 set cloud
iam roles
before you can use cloud dlp to send
scan results to security command center
you'll need to enable some cloud iam
roles this section requires you to have
the organization administrator iam
role click on the organization drop-down
list and select the organization for
which you want to enable security
command center
navigate to iam and admin using the
navigation pane
find the username in the member column
or add a new user
add the roles security center admin and
dlp jobs editor
and then click save
step 3. enable security command center
if you are a new user
enable security command center following
the instructions in the 3-step
overview video linked below
step four enable cloud dlp
navigate to the project you would like
to use to execute your dlp scan
the project must be within the same
organization where you enabled security
command center
head to apis and services in the
navigation pane
search for cloud dlp api and enable it
step 5 enable cloud dlp as a security
source for security command center
go to the security command center page
and select your organization
click settings in the top right corner
of the page
under integrated sources click the
toggle next to data loss prevention
step 6. define a dlp inspect job
go to the cloud dlp console and choose
your project
click on create job enter a name
and select the storage target that you
want to scan
configure your scan options
on the actions step click to enable
publish to security command center
you also have the option to save the
results to bigquery
click create and run the job if you want
to surface findings for additional
projects within your organization
repeat step 6 for each storage asset
that you want to inspect
now findings for cloud dlp will display
in the findings tab of the security
command center dashboard
cloud dlp uses information types or info
types to define what it scans for
an info type is a type of sensitive data
such as a name
email address telephone number
identification number
credit card number and so on you can
also define your own custom info types
or tune detection using inspection rules
you can find out more about it in the
cloud dlp documentation
in our environment we see that there
have been more than 90 cloud dlp
findings in our organization
such as email addresses credit card
numbers and phone numbers
drilling in let's expand an email
address finding we can see it first
occurred on august 25th and is located
in the asset we identified for our
inspect job
this is the project in which the pii was
flagged
we can then click on the external uri
source and see almost 4 000 pii findings
related
to it next if setup is part of the dlp
job
we can perform additional analysis on
this data through bigquery
or we can remove this resource and
remediate these findings by contacting
the owner
congratulations you've enabled cloud dlp
for security command center
and learned how to respond to a finding
from it
you